everyone knows that game development is
no walk in the park and the last two
years haven't made it any easier we
started to see games get delayed last
year including some major aaa releases
but the real effect of this seems to be
from games that were already planned for
2021 as teams had to use new work from
home setups that delayed processes and
ultimately slowed down development with
that said here is our list of game
delays in 2021 drop a like if you
enjoyed the list and subscribe to
gamespot for more videos just like this
after a few stage presentations official
character breakdowns and the tease of a
beta the team over at criterion have
officially delayed battlefield 2042 an
official statement that was published on
their twitter explains that the
complications of making a game during a
global pandemic have led them to
officially push back the launch day to
november 19 2021 the upside is that it
was only pushed back a few weeks from
its original october 22nd date so we
won't have to wait
long following weeks of rumors that went
unanswered sony officially confirmed
that horizon forbidden west has been
delayed during gamescom's opening night
live event the game is now arriving on
february 18th 2022 but a patch that
bumps up the original game to 60 frames
per second was released the same day
ostensibly to make the game wait a
little easier it leaves the ps5 without
a major exclusive aaa game release this
holiday season though
evil dead the multiplayer horror game
based on the famous horror comedy series
was planned for either a late 2021
release or an early 2022 release
the latest expected date is february of
2022 with the development team saying
they will be able to add a single player
option with the extra time groovy
god of war ragnarok was originally
scheduled to release at some point this
year however santa monica studio has
opted to delay the game into 2022 in
order to ensure that it meets the series
high quality standards
playstation's head of worldwide studios
hermann hulse said that the project
started a little later than some others
which may have contributed to the delay
less game and more guitar learning tool
ubisoft's rocksmith plus will no longer
be releasing in 2021 a final date hasn't
been announced but it's planned to
launch sometime in 2022 the company said
that its new plan will quote give us
time to deliver a smooth experience for
all guitar and bass lovers
the latest game in the acclaimed
strategy series total war warhammer 3
has slipped into early 2022. developer
creative assembly said that this time
will make for a stronger release and
that while it's the last game in the
trilogy it will be supported for years
with new content
the free to play mmorpg lost ark is
getting a closed beta in 2021 but
developers smilegate and publisher
amazon games opted to delay the game in
order to bring back its launch quality
up to the team's standards and implement
new content from the korean version the
game is now coming out in early 2022
though the closed beta arrives in
november and anyone who bought the
founders pack will get access
the next game from the guacamelee studio
drinkbox nobody saves the world was
bumped to early 2022 as the developer
works on implementing online cooperative
play
it's the first game with such a feature
the studio has made with guacamelee only
supporting local co-op mode at launch
the game will be on xbox game pass and
is coming to xbox series s
x xbox one and pc
originally scheduled for a late 2021
release abandoned from blue box game
studios will now arrive at a later date
very little is known about the project
and questions surrounding its unclear
messaging and seemingly intentional
teases to hideo kojima and silent hill
have brought some controversy to the
project there is no evidence that kojima
is involved and the developer has said
this outright several times
radiate dawn has been a subsidiary of
oculus for some time now and the studio
works exclusively on vr games one of
these lone echo 2 was going to be among
the biggest games available on oculus
devices and while it's still scheduled
for 2021 a recent delay has pushed it to
later in the year after already being
delayed from 2019 2020 and 2021
in order to alleviate pressure on the
development team which is also finishing
up life's strange true colors the
decision was made to delay life is
strange remastered collection this
bundle will now come out in 2022 and
includes the upgraded versions of life
is strange and life is strange too
the nintendo switch version of true
colors will also be coming out later
than expected however it's still slated
for the end of 2021
diablo mortal was announced a few years
ago as a mobile exclusive spin on the
dungeon crawling rpg however that
timeline has shifted to 2022 and
blizzard said it's using its time to add
controller support and work out both pve
and pvp content 8 player raids are now
one of the biggest features added to the
game
everyone knows soup tastes better when
it takes more time to simmer and chicken
clubs soup pot will be doing just that
the game is now coming to xbox platforms
and pc later this year in order to give
the developer more time for polishing
you'll be doing live streams of your
cooking in the game to make over 100
dishes
long-awaited sci-fi survival game icarus
created by dayz creator dean hall was
originally planned to launch in august
of 2021 however now it's coming out in
november without a finalized specific
date but there will be multiple beta
periods over the next few months before
the game's launch
[Music]
quick shout out to halo infinite while
technically it shouldn't be on this list
in august of 2020 infinite was delayed
for december of 2021 things finally
appear to be on track and 343 industries
has even held some technical tests for
members of its halo insider program
let's hope that december of 2021 is
still looking like the rock solid date
[Music]
stray was supposed to arrive in 2021
bringing us the tale of an adorable cat
just struggling to survive in a world
taken over by robots however the
development team has opted to delay the
game until 2022 so as not to compromise
on quality
[Music]
first revealed with a gameplay trailer
in 2020 and planned for a 2021 launch
the open world spin-off to black desert
online crimson desert is now arriving at
an unspecified future date as pearl
abyss works to add new ideas to make it
a quote deeper more enriching game
[Music]
no stranger to delays digimon survive
was originally announced three years ago
and planned to launch in 2020 before
those plans were thrown into disarray at
the earliest it's now coming in q3 of
2022 and based on the language of toei
animation's latest financial report it
could very well be even later than that
[Music]
just a month after rainbow six
extraction was reintroduced to the
public via the ubisoft e3 presentation
the company opted to delay the game into
january of 2022 the spin-off of the main
series focuses on an alien threat which
is a big departure for the franchise and
with support planned for cross play and
cross progression the development team
evidently needed extra time
[Music]
originally planned to launch in 2021
warhammer dark tide has been pushed to
spring of 2022 in order to give the
development team more time for polishing
and ensuring the game's longevity post
launch what exactly that means remains
to be seen but it'll release on xbox
series x and s and pc
a game first scheduled to come out with
resident evil village that was later
delayed already to july
resident evil reverse will bring its
take on multiplayer to players in 2022
a third-person shooter with characters
from across the series history it also
makes use of some environments from the
classic games in the series as well
tango gameworks ghostwire tokyo looks to
be quite a big departure from its evil
within series but we haven't actually
seen much of the game and that didn't
bode well for making it a 2021 release
it's now coming out in early 2022 in
order to better meet the studio's vision
the king of fighters 15 suffered a delay
from a vague window to a slightly less
vague window moving from some point in
2021 to q1 of 2022 snk made the
announcement just before e3 this year
saying the increasing cases of coven 19
in japan have affected development
it'll be the first new game in the
series since 2016 with famous returning
characters from fatal fury akari
warriors and the art of fighting also
appearing
it's easy to forget that the ubisoft
open world pirate game skull and bones
is still even in development but it is
and the company reminded investors
during the earnings call of may 2020
the game has been delayed entirely out
of the current fiscal year meaning it
won't arrive until april 2022 at the
very earliest
the game was first announced back in
2017 and has undergone development
shakeups including getting a new
creative director
studio managing director hughes reichor
also left his position in late 2020 over
harassment and bullying allegations
the highly anticipated five nights at
freddy's security breach looks like it
will be a major setup for the indie
horror series but the developers need
more time to fully realize their vision
as such the game has been delayed until
late 2021 but series creator scott
coffin also released a free game called
security breach fury's rage as a
consolation gift it's heavily inspired
by the streets of rage series
lego star wars the skywalker saga has
been delayed to an unclear future date
traveler's tales did not give an exact
reason for the delay other than wanting
to give the team more time to deliver
quote the biggest and best ever lego
game and said it would provide new
launch information as soon as it can
sony confirmed back in february that
gran turismo had been delayed into 2022
the decision came as critical parts of
the development process were affected by
the pandemic and because of the changing
nature of the global situation a firm
date wasn't set as we get closer to the
next year that'll likely change
originally scheduled to release back in
february ubisoft delayed its extreme
sports game writer's republic to
september but it was delayed again until
october 28th of 2021
we won't be able to get our hanzis on
the lord of the rings golem until 2022
the game's planned 2021 launch got
pushed earlier in the year with
companies daedalic entertainment and
nikon partnering on the project moving
forward it's planned to release on
several different systems including the
xbox series s and x xbox one ps5 ps4
nintendo switch and pc
[Music]
originally planned for a launch this
march the prince of persia sands of time
remake was delayed to an unclear future
date back in february ubisoft sighting
wanting to make a remake that still
feels fresh while staying true to the
spirit of the original version but they
didn't specify how long the delay would
be or if it's still even planned for
2021 the series has largely been on ice
since assassin's creed exploded in
popularity over a decade ago
hogwarts legacy a game set in the 19th
century of harry potter's world was
scheduled to release later this year but
has been delayed to 2022 the delay came
amid controversy surrounding author jk
rowling who was not directly involved
with the project
gotham knights a spin-off of the batman
series a non-canonical one was scheduled
to arrive before the end of 2021 before
being bumped into next year warner
brothers gave a very vague statement
about wanting to provide the best
possible experience for players unquote
but did not specify the reason behind
the delay the co-op action game is
directed by patrick redding who
previously worked on the splinter cell
series and far cry it's only one dc game
warner brothers has cooking with a
suicide squad game also coming in 2022
however we wouldn't be shocked if that
got bumped as well
[Music]
a game awash in controversy and
production issues vampire the masquerade
bloodlines 2 got delayed late last year
to a 2021 date since then publisher
paradox chose to delay the game again
this time out of 2021 completely
furthermore a new developer is working
on the project replacing hard suit labs
which was subsequently hit with layoffs
it's also one of the few troubled
projects that previously involved writer
chris avalon who was later accused of
sexual misconduct though none of his
contributions are being used
[Music]
dying light 2 has been delayed a few
different times and was originally
scheduled to release about a year ago a
delay announcement back in january was
indefinite though it was still confirmed
for 2021 and the game was later
confirmed to launch in december
specifically this delay came after
techland was accused of a toxic work
environment and poor leadership writer
chris avalone also worked on dying light
2 and left the project amid sexual
misconduct allegations and that delay
wasn't the last with the game later
being moved to february of 2022
spiritual successor to left 4 dead back
for blood was delayed from june 22nd
till october 12th the studio didn't give
any concrete information about the
reason behind the delay aside from
wanting to improve the game
since then we've had the alpha and the
beta and everything appears to be on
track for the october 12th release
[Music]
capcom's pragmata was shown off in 2020
as a showcase for the ps5 but the game
already received a delay this isn't
coming out until 2023 meaning it's
probably going to be a long time before
we hear more about the game at all all
we do know is that it's scheduled to
launch on pc playstation 5 and xbox
series s and x
[Music]
amazon's mmo new world has been delayed
more times than we can count seemingly
one of the only games amazon hasn't
canceled outright new world has moved
from a vague spring 2021 window to
august 31st of 2021 that seemed like it
was going to hold after a successful
beta but now the game is supposed to
release september 28th
planned to launch in november the
expansion in destiny 2 the witch queen
has been delayed into 2022 the scope and
complexity of the expansion and its
narrative ties to other content was one
of the reasons for the delay and the
studio also wanted to avoid putting
extra pressure on the development team
during the pandemic however content for
the game including the vault of glass
raid will continue throughout 2021
let us know in the comments which games
you were bummed to see get delayed over
and over and let us know if we missed
anything drop a like if you enjoyed the
list and subscribe to gamespot for more
videos just like this